[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica siete días a
usted de su magazine 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz y estos son nuestros
titulares varios países del sur de
áfrica se han visto aislados por
restricciones impuestas alrededor del
mundo con las que se intenta detener la
propagación de la variante omicron de el
coronavirus descubierta en sudáfrica el
presidente sudafricano dijo que estas
medidas dañarán sus economías e instó a
que haya igualdad en la distribución de
las vacunas
la campaña de demonización en gambia con
la que se busca acabar con el apoyo se
ha visto interrumpida por la
desconfianza en torno a las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 el país que había
sido declarado libre de poliomielitis en
2004 ahora detectó el temido virus en
muestras de aguas residuales
en ruanda una iglesia evangélica se
enfrenta a los religiosos más
conservadores y acoge a miembros de la
comunidad lgtb
y aunque la homosexualidad no está
prohibida en este país las personas de
orientación sexual diversa se enfrentan
constantemente a la discriminación
empezamos hablando de o micro en la
nueva variante de coronavirus
descubierta en sudáfrica que ha
provocado una ola de restricciones a
nivel mundial este nuevo linaje del
virus cuenta con múltiples mutaciones y
la organización mundial de la salud lo
calificó como de preocupación y aunque
todavía se llevan a cabo investigaciones
para determinar la amenaza que
representa omicron ya empieza a crear
pánico varios países han empezado a
blindarse y han restringido los vuelos
provenientes de hasta 8 naciones del sur
de áfrica estas prohibiciones contra la
región llegan justo para la temporada de
vacaciones cuando esperaban reactivar
sus economías y han recibido la condena
de líderes africanos con live in the
project vision lo único que eran estas
prohibiciones es dañar aún más las
economías de los países afectados y
socavar su capacidad para responder y
también para recuperarse de la pandemia
de inversión soft de omicron ver bien
la aparición de la variante omicron
debería ser un llamado de atención al
mundo de que no se puede permitir que
continúe la desigualdad de vacunas
mientras todos no estén vacunados
seguirán en riesgo hasta que todos estén
vacunados tendremos que esperar que más
variantes sigan emergiendo united we
should expected to be giants walking on
image y para analizar este tema
saludamos en ciudad del cabo a josé
francisco fernández médico colombiano
que reside en esa ciudad de sudáfrica y
quien además es jefe médico de una
clínica en angola doctor bienvenido a
áfrica siete días háblenos de esta
variante hay alerta hay pánico lo que
está provocando cierres de fronteras son
estrictas medidas muy similares a las
que se aplicaron cuando empezó la
pandemia esta es una variante que
amerita todas estas restricciones en
realidad deberíamos preocuparnos
bueno pues esta es una variante
catalogada por la organización mundial
de la salud como preocupante lo que sí
amerita
mucha atención por parte de todos los
países
sin embargo lo que se percibe en los
países del sur del continente africano
es que después de escribir esta variante
de hacerla conocerás del mundo se generó
una serie de respuestas que se ha
considerado como excesivas que algunos
presidentes de la zona han catalogado
como anti africanas o como una especie
de nuevo aparte y esto lo que ha
generado mucha molestia sobre todo
porque se siente que están aislando el
continente africano sobre todo a los
países del sur del continente y esto
obviamente genera molestias en el día el
doctor sabemos que áfrica es el
continente donde las vacunas podría
decirse de alguna manera están llegando
a cuentagotas tiene esto algo que ver
con el surgimiento de esta nueva
variante
si definitivamente se ha demostrado que
entre en menos vacunación allá y más
expuestos estén los individuos es más
fácil para el virus mutar y esto es
justamente lo que pasó con esta nueva
variante llamado micro no hay tantas
mutaciones de las diferentes proteínas y
posiblemente esto ocurrió dentro del
organismo de la persona no vacunada o
inmunosuprimidas y esto lleva a que los
virus desarrollen
proteínas que ayuden a evadir los
anticuerpos a evadir las vacunas hacia
el de pronto más infecciosos a ser más
letales esto es muy probablemente por
ahí es la cosa por la falta de vacunas
para falta de acceso a vacunas que
permite al virus mutar y desarrollar una
manera diferente de infectarnos
doctor se están detectando cada vez más
nuevos casos en país en varios países
principalmente en europa pero cuál es la
situación en sudáfrica y sus naciones
vecinas
pues en este momento en sudáfrica
estamos entrando en lo que pareciera ser
la cuarta ola
hace un par de semanas los números eran
muy bajos injustamente por en un aumento
inesperado de los números en las últimas
dos semanas porque se empezó a estudiar
y se descubrió esta variante actualmente
se habla de una auditora de dore del 9.5
casi el 10 por ciento de positividad de
las pruebas lo cual nos hace pensar que
estamos entrando en el cuarto pico que
sea solamente de un micro o no que sea
de delta aún no tengo estos datos pero
definitivamente un micro si está jugando
un papel importante en esto en cuanto a
los demás países del sur del áfrica
los tests ahí todavía no se muestra un
aumento en cuanto a los a los a los
casos positivos pero posiblemente es
porque en sudáfrica seas más test por
personas que esté aquí y aquí es donde
se ve esa tendencia al aumento y muy
poco tiempo veremos la misma tendencia
en los demás países doctor fernández
muchas gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
áfrica siete días y cambiamos de tema y
es que además de la escasez de vacunas
que afecta a áfrica la desinformación en
torno a estos fármacos
no solo afecta a las campañas de
inmunización contra el kobe 19 sino
también a otras contra otras
enfermedades como es el caso de la polio
en gambia este país que había sido
declarado libre de poliomielitis en 2004
lanzó una campaña de vacunación a
mitades de noviembre después de haber
detectado el temido virus en muestras de
aguas residuales en agosto pero ahora el
proceso se ha ralentizado debido a la
desconfianza en torno al inmunizando y
contra el kobe 19 la polio es una
enfermedad que ataca la médula espinal y
se transmite de persona a persona afecta
principalmente a los niños menores de 5
años y se puede prevenir mediante la
vacunación
creo que el principal obstáculo que
encontramos ahora mismo en el campo
tiene que ver con la vacunación de kobe
que se viene realizando la gente tiene
la percepción de que esta es una vacuna
que vino a acabar con la raza negra que
está hecha por los blancos para acabar
con la raza negra entonces con esta
situación hemos estado en el campo para
la vacunación contra el cob y 19 es otra
campaña también seguida de esta vacuna
contra la polio entonces esta razón es
un obstáculo para la vacunación contra
la polio polio vaccination vamos ahora a
etiopía donde tras más de un año de
guerra entre las fuerzas gubernamentales
y los rebeldes de tigre en el norte del
país
los combates se acercan a la capital
addis abeba en vista de la evolución de
la situación militar francia pidió el
martes a sus ciudadanos que abandonen
sin demora el país precisando que
facilitará su salida en vuelos
comerciales antes que el país galo
varias otras naciones entre ellas el
reino unido eeuu instaron también a sus
ciudadanos a salir de etiopía mientras
que la onu comenzó a evacuar a las
familias de su personal internacional
pasamos a tanzania donde el gobierno
anuló una antigua ley que prohibía que
las jóvenes que quedaran embarazadas
mientras estaban en la escuela pudieran
retomar sus estudios la norma estaba
vigente desde el periodo colonial
británico y también aparecía en el
código penal de los años 60 y aunque no
todos los centros educativos le
aplicaban era defendida firmemente por
el fallecido ex presidente john mcfall y
según el fondo de población de las
naciones unidas- una de cada cuatro
adolescentes de entre 15 y 19 años son
madres por lo que esta ley impidió que
miles de alumnas completarán sus
estudios de acuerdo con cifras de la ong
centro de derechos reproductivos cada
año 8.000 estudiantes están sanas
dejaron de ir a clases por este motivo
en kigali la capital de ruanda una
iglesia evangélica predica la inclusión
radical y abre sus puertas a la
comunidad lgtb
en este país a pesar de algunos avances
legislativos las personas abiertamente
homosexuales entre ellas la comunidad
trans siguen enfrentándose a los
prejuicios y al acoso los detalles en el
informe de amal bergman
un lugar inesperado en urban da abre sus
puertas a la comunidad lgbt
desde hace 4 años la llamada iglesia de
dios en áfrica de wanda va a
contracorriente de las demás
instituciones religiosas rechazando
radicalmente los prejuicios y acogiendo
abiertamente las personas lg vete y
comas
dónde y quién lleva mucho tiempo
apoyando la causa en ruanda dirige la
iglesia que cuenta con dos pastores
homosexuales y una comunidad de 200
fieles aunque la mayoría de ellos se
identifican como heterosexuales
gold white lake no queremos que la gente
se quede fuera por su orientación sexual
su identidad de género su forma de
identificarse o su origen por eso hemos
creado una iglesia inclusiva
incluso en wanda es uno de los pocos
países africanos que firmó en 2011 una
declaración conjunta de la onu en la que
se condena la violencia contra las
personas lgtb de pumas las personas de
esta comunidad son a menudo despedidas
de sus trabajos y refugiadas por sus
familiares privadas de atención médica o
incluso golpeadas hoy por el ingeniero
cuando esta iglesia acababa de abrir sus
puertas la gente de esta comunidad no
era muy acogedora decían que esta
iglesia sólo acudía homosexuales y que
ninguna persona normal vendría a rezar
aquí pero gracias a los buenos gestos de
este lugar y al amor que ha demostrado
la comunidad se está volviendo poco a
poco más acogida de comitán y víctor
guaita de ayer iba caracterizando el
mundo chan chan amor y corriente
los integrantes de la comunidad son
optimistas en cuanto a que las cosas se
están moviendo en la dirección correcta
el director de la iglesia está
multiplicando las iniciativas en este
sentido y organizó una capacitación para
otros líderes eclesiásticos destinada a
luchar contra la discriminación
y finalizamos esta edición de áfrica
siete días con las imágenes del
imponente show al estilo faraónico que
tuvo lugar en egipto con un espectáculo
que ofreció una muestra de su amplia
riqueza cultural la ciudad de luxor
reabrió una antigua avenida de más de
3000 años conocida como la avenida de
las esfinges o el camino de los dioses
esta vía conecta a los famosos templos
de karnak y luxor en lo que fue la
ciudad de tebas que solía ser la capital
de egipto en la antigüedad esta es la
segunda ceremonia de esta magnitud que
se realiza en el país para honrar su
herencia y con el objetivo de reactivar
el turismo que es una de las principales
fuentes de su economía
de esta manera despedimos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días recuerde que si
quieres repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]